ce sont 120 jeunes qui ont découvert les
jardins du grand trianon entourée
d'arbres de fleurs et d'arbustes
ils visitent le domaine accompagnés de
leur guide yvan jardiner au château de
versailles
on a parlé du la différence entre un
jardin anglais un jardin français
en fait c'est l'une des spécificités du
jardin que j'entretiens c'est le jardin
anglais de marie-antoinette de qui c'est
le seul parti à l'anglais to versailles
c'est à dire que c'est des allées
sinueuses les arbres sont laissés encore
libres c'est un endroit où on doit
reproduire la nature on veut reproduire
les plus belles choses de la nature
contrairement aux jardins français où
tout est rectiligne toutes les droites
symétrique
cadres et même si le métier de jardinier
ne l'a pas séduite
mina collégienne à admirer les fleurs et
les statuts et a même pu goûter des
fruits cultivés dans le jardin on a
appris des nouvelles choses qu'on ne
savait pas par exemple on a mangé un
fruit tout à l'heure un fruit de la
forêt en fait on a cru que des camps
comme on dit que si tu as un poison en
fait c'est pas du tout un poison c'est
un truc qu'on mange et il a un goût de
comme la brique on va dire à l'intérieur
durant les trois ans du programme
les jeunes pourront découvrir des
métiers parfois originaux comme un
sellier maroquinier un parc et heures un
marbrier ou encore un tapissier on a
choisi de faire quelque chose qui se
rapproche plus d'une volonté de
permettre aux jeunes de découvrir
versailles sous un autre jour celui de
ses métiers de ses pratiques
professionnelles très diverse très
variées qu'on imagine pas toujours le
grand public d'une manière générale et
donc encore plus quand on est jeune et
qu'on sait pas trop qu'est ce qu'on a
envie de faire de son avenir
un projet qui permet à certains jeunes
de trouver leur orientation dans un
métier qu'ils ne connaissent pas au
coeur de versailles se terminera en 2021
de quoi créer encore quelques vocations